joining us now with Florida Congressman
Byron Donalds and former deputy
independent Council Saul weisenberg
Congressman let's start with you do you
think attorney general Garland has
committed an impeachable offense I think
I think he has and let's be very clear
you can't have the investigative arm of
the IRS doing its job wanting to bring
felony charges but then somehow with the
political brass at the IRS and the
political brass at the Department of
Justice it all gets slow walked it all
gets tamped down they can go get the
necessary search warrants they can't
interview the right people some of the
some of the stuff that came out is they
couldn't even pursue any use of the word
Biden in some of their questioning like
this is how ridiculous this is and so
for the Attorney General to not know and
to also add to this the chief of staff
to the attorney general not to know
what's going on makes no sense at all
well not knowing would be ignorance but
would it be an impeachable offense you
would have to say that he's lying before
Congress yes if he knew this well even
even if he didn't talk about it in front
of Congress if he used the power of his
office to slow walk and to obstruct
these investigations that is an
impeachable offense 100 now Saul you
think that the first step should be
having the AG and perhaps the US
attorney Weiss testify before Congress
so if that's the case what do you think
is the most important question for each
to have to answer
they they can do this if if they can
just not grandstand and screw it up
Laura they need to bring three people in
they need to bring David weissen the U.S
attorney from Delaware they need to
bring the Attorney General in and they
need to to bring in the person who's
probably in the thick of this and we
haven't heard anything from her that's
Deputy attorney general uh Lisa Monaco
the deputy attorney general runs the
Department of Justice on a day-to-day
basis I can guarantee you that if David
Weiss didn't pick up the phone to talk
to Merrick Garland it would have been in
all likelihood Lisa Monaco and the first
thing I would ask there's so many
questions to ask the first thing I would
ask why says
were you commissioned as a special
attorney this special attorney they keep
talking about that has the right to
bring a case in any District without
getting permission you actually have to
be designated and commissioned now A.G
Garland says he had the authority from
the beginning to do anything he wanted
to he had more Authority than a special
counsel because he was a special
attorney well when were you commissioned
do you even now have a commission it
looks like from his last letter that he
did not have a commission were you
telling here's a very simple thing that
he hasn't spoken to did you tell the
agents that you had gone to the DC U.S
attorney Matthew Graves and that he had
declined to let you bring charges or to
use Weiss's terminology declined to
partner with you did the same thing
happen in California they can't say we
we can't talk about it because they've
already gone out right and explained
what Authority they had and didn't have
and what simple question what what
simple question quickly to Garland
simple question the Garland it's the
same question did you sign a commission
you say he had the authority did you did
you think did he actually sign you could
do it orally yeah so it's all right
Congressman on the letter that we sent
to uh Senator Graham noting this ongoing
investigation we keep talking about
here's how MSNBC spun this watch
is he seeing that flat out that this was
not politically interfered by Garland
nobody from the administration he went
where he needed to go he charged what he
thought he could charge and that this
deal that he made this plea deal is not
a sweetheart deal as Republicans and
this whistleblower or a legend Ken Well
we'd all like him to be that candid he's
constrained because the investigation
remains open so he's not saying all
those things
Here We Go Again Congressman the
investigation is ongoing or you can't
say it's because things aren't true
which is it well first of all it is a
sweetheart deal because any other
American would have been charged with a
felony crime even The Whistleblower who
was the head of the supervisory unit
doing the investigation said yeah we
wanted to bring felony charges but we
were stopped because David Weiss
couldn't bring those charges and we
weren't allowed to do it what is this
ongoing investigation this is what we we
don't know who's conducting it we don't
know if it's of the if it's of the
president then there has to be a special
counsel appointed you can't have the
justice department investigating the
president in my view what you have here
is this is the stall Walling effect by
the political arms of the Department of
Justice and in some respects the FBI as
well if it's always under investigation
I never have to get to an end point
until it's too late that's how the the
statue of limitations expired under
Hunter Biden with the other money just
keep it going so so I'd like you to
chime in on that we don't really know
anything about this continuing
investigation do we
oh I don't think they're we don't and I
don't think there's any kind of a
serious continuing investigation and
what a farce if it's being handled by by
David Weiss but let me just make
something really clear forget about
anything else about the bribery
allegations I'm going to tell you as a
white collar defense attorney for the
past 20 years who's handled a lot of tax
cases what you need to change a
misdemeanor into a felony is an
affirmative Act of concealment and the
record is already from the
whistleblowers uh abundant in that let
me give you a hint if you take your if
you take your girlfriend to a sex club
and then expense that is a business
expense That's a classic affirmative Act
of concealment if you lie to your
attorney who asks you questions about
why you did this on your taxes that's a
an affirmative Act of concealment it's
it's not even close uh pretty obvious
here congressman and Saul great to see
you both thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else